olá como vocês podem ver o rosto do etco
estrito eu por esse tipo de uso de véus
pretos
assim o time ta porque anderson preto
pousar sob a sombra de bola chega de
monsul eu nem faço anos mas tecnicamente
é hoje porque porque estou a fazer este
vídeo um tem que hoje é porque eu sei o
quê pra vir aqui porque eu seria uma
prenda foi quem o sim de uma loja e eu
venho ajudar a abrir a caixa etapa que
além de piloto é caixa eu disse estou
mudo de câmbio e motor que goiatuba e
matou a advogada responsável também por
trabalhar em nossa juventude quarto não
sei que eu acho civil pronto sabe sim
palhaços top 5 só vocês querem uma magia
eu vou fazer uma trip voto o uma pedra
o balanço subiu só quem viu esta
balançando rodas inteligente foi que
esta loja o fcs em pessoal espero que
seja também há uma semana cheia do edson
bora fazer este show
ontem que o manual dentro o que ensina
tudo é como você já não usar pc to go e
cenas aqui e ouviu só que tem que ser o
iphone por aqui dentro do agora mil
views 36 voltas que megan volkswagen que
isso tem um peso muito sol
o solo está o esanyol é só penetração em
branco porque eu podia preto mas claro
não tinham enviaram em branco mas mesmo
assim esteve por aqui em nosso e agora
vemos que isso funcione sul esteve
basicamente e horizontal e tem duas
rodas nem obviamente e postei aqui esta
tipo prancheta oi
e quando vocês carregam para frente não
vai pra frente quando vai atrás de
estarem por trás e não sendo que desliga
acho que a equipe que estamos temos aqui
com o botão do tipo é livro tenha que
esta estava inteira atrás tem que provar
digital tac os khanty agora vamos
experimentar esta meu eu coloquei tanta
vez meu eu já tenho experimentar um cada
um ys filmar e veja só o que aconteceu
eu estudo por outro lado e já caminha
que esta coisa
o méxico é um caminhão tipo à frente que
o avanço foi mais um povo
costa
a meta cheia
o anjo
ae
o cara vem um carro saía do condomínio
escuta e olha aí olha isso pirataria só
marcos ubiratan rodrigues
bebi bebi bebi
então é isso pessoal já deu para
experimentar aqui escuta meu esta cena é
brutal
passei pelo site de cinema de rec foi à
loja que enviou esta escuta meu som
brutais em ter enviado está salva
enquanto que o vasto leque favorito
fiquem bem e até a próxima
os quatro que ainda agora